je me sens plus à l'aise devant
quelqu'un comme ça que si j'étais
habillé autrement quelque part c'est une
façon de de faire ressortir la haine qui
qui est en moi
[Musique]
quoi quand je me l c'est une façon de me
mettre en scène parce que j'ai décidé
que la vie était une grande pièce de
théâtre à certains jours ça pouvait être
un grand opéra parfois un grand
na à une époque surtout je me prenais
pour une sorte de personnage de bande
dessiné un petit peu égaré à la Mad Max
tu vois entre les steps arabes et le
punk eran et puis c'est vrai qu'à
certains moment il y a des soirs où tu
as envie de ressembler à un personnage
du 19e siècle alors on met un Jabo une
que de P
oui c'est vrai que c'est une
matérialisation des rêves quand je je
fais des photos avec Antoine et ça me
permet de concrétiser tout ce que
j'aimerais faire dans la rue à Paris
c'est impossible tu as toujours la
banlieu qui te tombe dessus tu as
toujours des des gens idiots qui sont là
pour t'ennuyer et cetera je ne peux
vraiment pas le faire donc j'ai trouvé
ce billet d'exulter tout ça dans les
photos que je réalise avec
[Musique]
Antoine
j'ai une folie mais elle me plaît mais
ça aussi c'est une démarche que j'ai
trouvé seul quand on te montre du doigt
parce que tu es un peu fou quand tu es
enfant ou adolescent tu dis mais c'est
mal c'est pas bien et puis finalement
quand tu positives les choses tu te dis
mais finalement c'est pas si mal que
ça quand j'ai découvert B j'avais 9 ans
c'était en
74 je suis tombé sur une pochette de
disque où il était mais complètement
androgyne presque animal quoi comme une
chimère une chimère humaine c'était
quelqu'un à la fois sans sexe et avec
les deux
sexes j'ai voulu m'identifier un peu à
lui l'androgynie est quelque chose qui
m'a interpellé parce que déjà enfant ça
arrivait souvent comme'a appeler
mademoiselle j'ai demandéis à ma mère
coupe-moi les cheveux à peine sorti même
avec les cheveux courts c'était bonjour
mademoiselle j'ai toujours quelque chose
d'androgine si je chante c'est avec une
voix aigu
euh j'ai fait la paix avec moi-même je
suis en harmonie avec ma partie
masculine et ma partie
féminine et je suis vraiment bien dans
ma
peau et puis a déboulé un jour le
punk avec la diva du punk Nina
Hagen
[Musique]
ben voilà STATIS mannequin en vieille
reli punk on a ressorti les vieilles
reliques d'il y a 15 ans déjà 15 16 ans
alors ce sont mes mes petits vêtements
fétiches que j'ai tout le temps gardé
ils ont fait les concerts de ninaagen de
SII au début des années 80 donc mon
premier pantalon punk le t-shirt de
l'Union Jack destroyé comme on
disait j'étais séduit tout simplement
par la panoplie quoi c'était délirant
j'était en Angleterre à cette époque là
ça n fusquait personne dans la rue
c'était presque
[Musique]
naturel c'est difficile de changer de
look de passer d'une sorte de pseudo
idéologie à une autre il y a
effectivement un moment de
deuil je crois que quand tu arrives au
bout d'un
look si tu ne le supportes plus c'est
que intérieurement tu as changé et que
les événements extérieurs ont changé
et il y a un cocon qui s fait il y a une
crisealide et il y a un nouveau papillon
qui renaît
quoi
après
1980 il y avait les romantiques c'était
un mouvement qu'on appelle post punk les
hommes pouvaient se maquiller moi c'est
un truc que j'ai toujours gardé c'est un
geste un rituel que je fais tous les
jours c'est un plaisir aussi de le faire
les nouveaux romantique on donné
naissance ensuite au look
gothique il y avait la espce du gothique
c'était
suy comme le punk était mort c'est une
sorte de résurrection macabre je dirais
ce sont des looks noirs les dentelles
noires maquillage
noir j'ai adoré en effet avoir ce visage
blême ses lèvres noires ses yeux cernés
qu'on rêve d'avoir quand on est
adolescent et qu'on ne veut plus avoir
quand on a
vieilli un côté un peu hamelette tu vois
j'adis ça je me suis trallé dans des bar
avec un crâne dans la main je POS mon
crâne sur un mouchoir de dentelle et je
demandais à ce qu'on me serve un Bloody
Mary parce que ça ressem à du
[Musique]
sang 27 ans je suis 6 de
mode j'ai une passion pour l'AR
gothtique tout ce qui est musique
médiévale j'adore tout ce qui est
monument tout ce qui est architecture
gothique
baroque je suis
[Musique]
gothique j'aime bien tout ce qui est
vêtements noirs velour lira
PVC j'ai bien babill avec des pantalons
moulant des
robes des
capes j'aime bien avoir des bagues
j'aime bien
sentirçon j'aime bien l'argent donc
j'aime bien sentir le métal mais c'est
vrai que ça fait un plus dans le look
quand
même techno ce que j'aime à Cologne ce
qu'on trouve pas à Paris c'est
l'accueil la prière fois que j'ai
rencontré Edie et Michael c'est dans la
rue moi je cherch des boîtes de nuit
gothique passé la soirée
syptis il m' dit viens mon magasin j'ai
des vêtements et tout on a discé j'ai
magasin sur
Paris pouro pas je pas
vê la plupart des gens sont trop timides
pour porter ce qu'ils
aiment nous on s'habille vraiment comme
on veut c'est pas le carnaval carnaval
c'est seulement une fois par an c'est
l'occasion pour les gens de être heureux
d'avoir un look étrange et d'être
tolérant pour 3 ou 4 jours et ça c'est
de la
merde la Cologne gothique on connait on
le connait tous quand je va des soirées
j'aime bien rencontrer d'autres gens des
gens nouveaux que j'ai jamais vu on nous
présente à tout le monde on sent à
l'aise même quand toi les connais
[Musique]
pas
la géographie n'a plus d'importance nous
prenons tous les mêmes avions nous
sommes tous reliés à Internet nous
coupons le monde en TR comme un gâteau
et nous disons ces gens qu'il soi à
Paris à Londres à New York à Tokyo
apptienent à la même tribu que les gens
qui sont
ici triste c'est c'est compliqué à dire
j'ae bien m'amuser tout ça mais le
contexte où je vais passer mes
soirées milieu que je fréquente c'est
triste par moi tout ce qui est triste
est
beau beaucoup de mes amis sont gothiques
ils veulent explorer une philosophie et
une vision de la vie très
sombre mais Jeon sat et au discipl du
[Musique]
diable ce sont des gens qui comprennent
la tragédie et la beauté des émotions
fortes ça c'est un truc à faire
toutonde
jours jours
la extrême droite on n pas gauche on est
pas centre on est aucune politique notre
politique c'est notre musique c'est un
milieu Pacifique c'est l'égalité de tout
le
[Musique]
monde quand j'entre dans un café j'ai
pas de problème ils ont pas peur bon
c'est sûr quand on arrive la première
fois c'est un peu impressionnant
connaêre le fond de la personne quand
même essayer de de voir se derrière la
pararence c'est vrai que ça donne un
genre c'est tout on n pas peut-être
qu'on s'identifie à un mouvement
peut-être qu'on s'identifie à pas mal de
choses mais je crois que le plus
important d'abord c'est que nous on se
sente bien c'est de l'égoïsme mais je
crois que c'est ça le plus important moi
je me sens plus à l'aise devant
quelqu'un comme ça que si j'étais
habillé autrement il y a déjà un côté
esthétique que je trouve bien et puis
bon là c'est pas que c'est la c'est pas
que la douleur me plaît quoi mais c'est
pour voir jusqu'où je peux jusqu'où je
peux aller quoi et quelque part c'est
une façon de de faire ressortir la de
faire ressortir un peu la la haine qui
qui est en moi
[Musique]
quoi c'est vrai que c'est dur j'ai TR
travailler avec un
look excentrique passer commandes au
début j'étais pas embauché comme
styliste je travaillais comme vendeur
parce que c'est vrai qu' un vendeur avec
un look et tout ça dans ce milieu-là ça
accroche les clients puis après il a vu
que j'avais une passion pour faire des
vêtements tout le métier que je sais
maintenant c'est lui qui me l'a appris
de A à Z sans école ti tu vois on va
voir ça laaveste tu vas l'essayer on va
voir les retouches qu'il y a à faire
puis maintenant le patron c'est comme un
père voilà la fiction l'an 2000
l'hologramme voilà ça c'est ça va être
la dernière collection qu'on va faire
tout va être basé sur sur l'IT le rêve
moi j'ai jamais fait attention au look
des gens bon Laurent m'a intéressé parce
que je trouve c'est quelqu'un qui est
qui ne triche pas tel que vous le voyez
dans la rue tel qu'il est chez lui ça
c'est très rare parce qu'en général tout
le monde joue la
[Musique]
comédie
je ne supporte pas l'idée d'avoir les
mêmes vêtements que
quiconque mais même au sein des
marginaux je veux être
différent c'est quel genre de te tu en
général c'est le un te clair pour des te
clair
clair poudre compa mon look c'est une
synthèse d'un petit peu tout ce que j'ai
vécu mais bon maintenant c'est vrai que
c'est orienté plus vers les années
70 c'est
aussi un mélange
mystique côté mystique est plus sur mon
visage c'est le Home que je dessine
toujours sur mon
front c'est un petit peu un symbole de
paix et d'amour ce sont les bonnes
énergies la bonne
Rayonnance
je suis végétarien je respecte la vie
animale je banis la fourrure et le cuir
plus possible ça aussi ça fait partie du
[Musique]
look le problème des gens à look il faut
qu'il sache que à l'extérieur
obligatoirement même si on ne veut pas
provoquer c'est une provocation donc il
faut accepter aussi le fait que des gens
vont nous insulter ou nous cracher
dessus
[Musique]
un mélange de
force qu'est-ce qui est normal et
qu'est-ce qui est anormal est-ce normal
d'avoir un costume cravate une Mercedes
rempli de cocaïne et de la vendre à à
des gosses qui vont en crever ou est-ce
anormal d'avoir mon look un peu cinglé
et d'avoir une vie sans sans cigarette
sans al sans drogue où est la
[Musique]
normalité
N